We've already talked a lot about
finding features, detecting them,
describing them and matching them.
And so, we're not going to do much more
in terms of that feature matching for
motion, okay?
Instead, what we're going to be doing
over the next couple times is focusing
on the dense methods where
we look at the derivatives,
we look at how things change.
And just to sort of spill
the beans all the way at the end,
the best methods currently,
use a combination of the,
the feature to get
the long-range matches and
local gradients in order to
get the dense shorter range.
So you already know about
the feature stuff, so
now we need to go over
the dense direct stuff.
And that's what we're going to be
doing over the next couple of lessons.